to use that inimitable phrase you really
couldn't make it up army top brass have
kicked off a major stink by suggesting
male troops can wear makeup currently
only female soldiers can wear cosmetics
while on duty but obsessed with proving
the Army is quotes an inclusive employer
some senior ranking duffer's have
announced they could bring this in as
part of making the military more gender
neutral what virtue signalling vacuous
Ness is it any wonder the Army has
thousands of soldiers short of its
recruitment target what with this latest
lunacy and a multi-million pound
advertising campaign targeting phone
zombies snowflakes and men who weep you
be excused for wondering just who the
hell they're targeting to sign up while
it must provide emotional support to its
troops the arm is designed to protect
this nation and its interests
regrettably that might sometimes
necessitate killing people ordering a
male squad e to do that just after he's
applied his Rouge and blusher is plainly
nonsensical at the top brass con totally
bonkers in their bunkers you're
exorcised by this the Army is saying
that men who can wear makeup frankly I
just don't see what the fuss is about I
mean I think people in public service
however all people who are serving their
country doing as long as they're doing a
good job who really cares whether
they're wearing makeup or not let's find
out if any do you care no well the point
is if you're going to allow women to our
makeup in the army why wouldn't you
allow it because in some instances as I
pointed out perhaps in that introduction
we're going to require people do some
pretty
brutal things which if you've just come
out of the makeup salon might not quite
sit that well that doesn't answer my
question about why women are not men
because men I just don't see that that's
what you want to do if you do enough of
me I'd mention recruitment we know
there's a big problem with army
recruitment in particular I was just
certainly thinking of the stern ID Lord
Kitchener saying your country needs you
in 1914 that image stood angels he'd be
spinning in his grave at this ludicrous
attempt to feminize the army I'm tempted
I'm tempted to marry I'm tempted to make
a bad taste joke so I will you know if
you go and fight for Queen and country -
we didn't know they wanted to dress as
Queen a country I mean you know I think
that this will have done more to damage
recruitment prospects than to actually
prove it I also think it's made I think
it's made the army but of a
laughingstock which is not fair to this
look I understand that the army wants to
get past the stereotypes I get I get
that but like it or not the fact is that
a guy who's gonna sign up to go fight
and I had to die for his country it's
not the kind of guy who's gonna care
whether or not he can wear is supposed
to be a crack fighting force it's not
supposed to represent the comp the
composition of society but again why
would you allow women but not from 5% of
men wear makeup according to you go Paul
and quite frankly Daniel grey and he is
the founder of the war paint is really
personal story for me I got bullied in
middle school
Jews do our looked so now I suffer would
produce more fear every single day and
affects me greatly so my story is one
about mental health I use makeup to
build up my confidence help me overcome
my insecurities it's different for
everyone
people come to makeup for different ways
and for different reasons
this is my story and I hope that
warpaint can help others too so there's
lots of reasons why men will choose to
wear makeup just as there is with women
often quite often it does help people
feel more confident in life and you want
someone operating a submachine gun who's
not confident in life in life is not
relevant it's not germane to whether
they're wearing makeup I want them to be
able to operate that machinery whether
they're wearing mascara while they're
doing it they might be wracked with
emotional health issues these poor
individuals and you want them in the
ring there is a difference between
having self insecurity insecurity issues
regarding how you look and thinking you
can take on the Taliban or whether how
they're going to face battle that's what
the Army is calamitous Lee short of the
number of person a V spot-on
they actually recruit their own the Army
is outsource it to a company that thinks
it's a good idea to go after men who
weep and presumably men who wear makeup
conservative party conferences where I
had the great joy to be there of course
it was such fun I'm sure everybody
wishes they could be there to defense
actually Ben Wallace in my view got it
absolutely right consulting on men being
allowed to awake makeup
the answer is men will be allowed to
wear makeup in the army as long as it's
camouflage color color really that'll be
the absolutely right ear and I bumped
into him and spoke to in private and he
said this is exactly the worst sort of
virtue signaling that he's not going to
help army recruitment an army recruiting
is a big big problem for the government
let's all listen particularly the viewer
I'm going to tell you what the army have
actually said because they do seem to
change their tone initially it was as an
inclusive employer that recognizes a
diversity of its personnel we are
currently in the process of revising our
guidance in this area to make it gender
neutral now the pledge actually we
specifically want it went back to them
for clarification they said they changed
it the Army is a modern and inclusive
employer that recognizes the diversity
of our soldiers but Queens regulations
currently state the while on duty male
soldiers may not wear makeup Andrew you
and I have done enough press 7 scale
that's rowing back is it feels like it
to me absolutely the Army's top brass
sitting and having to discuss whether
they've got a whole unit to which is
dealing with gender neutral issues so we
mustn't talk about mankind people kind I
think you can't make this the underlying
assumptions you're making one that men
who cry are somehow worse for the army
when they're actually more likely to be
emotionally stable because they're
regulating their emotions properly
second what your back garden in trench
by a man who regularly burst into tears
regularly or somebody who I know is
emotionally stable enough to recognize
when that when their emotions need to be
really you're in a trench you want him
guarding your back yeah I would that'll
cheer up the people more into a deep
depression rather than somebody who's
bottled up all their emotions that can
explode it you know the liberal liberal
virtue sickening we get concerned with
ridiculous things this is one of the
most ridiculous things to be concerned
with I've seen it really as long as
people are able to do are you saying
that the women who wear makeup in the
army shouldn't they shouldn't be in the
army because how can you happen you're
great machine gun if you're covered in a
belief is that your
I've got the army regs fear me you've
let me into it nice
neatly even here's the rigs for makeup
one male's makeup is not to be worn two
females make up brackets if wall close
brackets is to be inconspicuous
brightly colored nail varnish is not to
be worn that for me works men allowed to
wear they pulled the machine gun trigger
Boris hasn't had the vest in time since
landing the table job this week things
nearly ground to halt the Prime Minister
was on his way to an event at his
party's conference in Manchester when
trouble started brewing no sooner had
one of the PM's aides handed him a cup
of takeaway coffee then another aide
understood to be number Ten's operations
chief Shelly Williams Walker snatched it
away saving him from a roasting by the
Khobragade later to social media to show
he had no hard feelings
Shelly Williams Walker for trying to
keep your boss out of hot water you are
are straight up snatcher of the week you
could say it was all just a storm in a
coffee cup it just shows they've gone so
environmentally-friendly remember
Michael Gove walking into number 10 just
days after announcing a big crackdown on
plastic and he didn't have a disposable
I mean after after the trees and mayor's
when she could suck the life out of room
the moment she started her speech it was
just it was noisy he put great infusing
there was no new lines in his speech but
it was well delivered
you know it's got the Tory party on site
you've enjoyed it Rachel I can't say
that enjoy is the right word okay we
expected that that's all we've got time
for this week but if you want to join in
the debate just search for the pledge on
Twitter and don't forget you can take
the debate with you by listening towards
on Apple podcasts Spotify or whichever
app you prefer thanks for watching